if dr. Frankenstein were real and alive
today he'd probably want to stop by the
Massachusetts General Hospital in Boston
here scientists are harvesting dead
organs and returning them to life but
instead of giant green monsters these
researchers are creating Hearts lungs
limbs and kidneys that could one day be
used to replace failing organs in people
reporting in Nature Medicine Harald OTT
and his team described their vision of
the future and how they created a
functional transplantable kidney in rats
what we try to do here is to regenerate
organs for transplantation organs for
patients with end-stage organ failure
using donor organs that would not
normally be suitable for transplantation
odds team reanimates them by first
washing away native cells with a soapy
solution what's left behind is a natural
scaffold of structural proteins that can
be repopulated with stem cells taken
from a patient what's fascinating is
that you you're able to with that
process preserve the blueprint of the
organ but it's completely washed emptied
it's a mayor a shadow of the original
tissue now the major hurdle here was to
get the cells the viable building blocks
back into the right spots within that
organ that we did through creating
literally a pressure gradient across the
kidneys so we were able to suck these
cells into the tissue into the kidneys
into the right spots the organs were
placed into chambers that simulate the
environment of a body complete with
oxygen and nutrients after a few days of
growth something remarkable happens the
tissue became functional so these
kidneys started to make a rudimentary
urine in the last step of this
experiment as the ultimate proof of
principle we were then able to take
these kidneys from culture and
Transplant them in an animal model so we
took that final step to take the kidney
out of the bioreactor and then treat it
like a transplant organ like a donor
organ and replace the native kidney
in an animal with this engineered kidney
but it's not always that easy we had to
figure out how much vacuum can be
applied to the kidney in order to
provide just the right amount of tissue
gradient to deliver the cells but not to
damage the matrix of course if more in
vacuum is applied though we have quite a
few kidneys blow up in a jar hiccups
aside laboratory-grown organs appear to
be closer and closer to fulfilling their
tremendous promise the reason why I'm
most excited about this recent
publication is because it shows the
platform character of this technology
the technology can be applied to any
tissue any organ that can be profused by
its own vascular system ultimately this
is a very translational kind of research
it's very much focused on driving this
all the way down to to the bedside
getting this to the patient